and the lefty we were talking about just
a minute ago swerving cole irvine taking
his 22nd turn of the season
and kite mentioned the tough luck loss
against the angels
but again i think it's about cole irvin
really starting to settle in and get a
feel for his entire pitch arsenal and
when and how he likes to deploy it
full count pitch
and this one line back up the middle
that's a base hit
second big league hit for yani hernandez
and all these 23 homers 64 rbis
eighth pitch of the at-bat and that ball
is hammered
holy moly did he get a hold of that one
what a shot
by adolesce garcia the rangers have a
two-nothing lead no
way
that fan caught that ball sticking his
head out the window
in a suite that's got to be the last
thing that he was ever thinking about
and i love your reverse jinx on the
rangers the struggles in the first
inning dave raymond you laid it out
there you built the graphic
and the rangers answered exactly how you
drew it up
for dolis garcia only one ball and they
tried to elevate up and in instead it
was out over the plate
and this is damn
good looking swing from garcia i mean
just absolutely hammered it
watch this guy
he's even it's okay it's coming our way
these buddies like come on get out of
here that's amazing
did he
this one's hit deep to left center field
marte's at the wall marte leaps up
against the wall that he caught it
absolutely incredible
marty tracking he does a good job of
picking up the wall early on
you can see where he
digs into the wall braces himself with
his throwing hand
we've seen this play so many times from
ramon laureano
for rangers they'll get to see drew
anderson for the first time in the
starting rotation these are his career
numbers just 12 games pitched at the big
league level
and he hits this ball with tom
but he got underneath it not going to
carry for him
jason martin is there and that's out
number one
olson lifts this one
not into short left field culberson
coming on quickly and he makes the play
3-2
and that's lifted out into left field
culverson going back this time and he
makes the catch and
drew anderson has a scoreless first
inning in his first rangers start
one-two pitch
and he bounces this one up the middle
counter-falef is there and throws out
kemp the inning is done and the a's
leave another man in scoring position
two on nobody out and he's batting
better than 300 with runners in scoring
positions
[Applause]
grounded
past the first baseman terry down the
right field line
one runs going to score marty the second
he makes it he's have second and third
nobody out and a run in
and here comes matt olson
driven down the third base line that's a
fair ball up against the wall two runs
are going to score also the second and
he is in there with a double
and that's a line drive base here down
the left field line
olson's going to score
lowry to third he's going to stop there
another double john gomes this time and
it's four to two
hurricane readies and comes to the plate
slider hit hard in the gap right center
field on the run peters at the wall and
up the top of the wall at the 362 sign
matt in the second slides with a double
two runs are home with lowry and gomes
the a's have exploded on texas and now
they lead it six to two so here's elvis
andrews who started the inning with a
walk
that's a base hit to right field another
run in for the a's as chapman trots home
seven to two
cole irvine has a seven to two lead
first pitch swinger andy ibanez drives
him toward kemp kemp leaps up and he
caught it
first pitch nice play get the action but
tony kemp
he's got to track this ball
not trying to take his eye off it and he
elevates backwards
not just up
here come the a's again two on nobody
out for yon gomes
here's the pitch fastball blasted deep
left center field martin is back to the
track at the wall and adios
into the camera well
john gomes a three-run homer
and it's 10-2 oakland
that was a moon shot
and john gomez's second home run as an
athletic
the new players in the green and gold
they have made their presence felt so
don't sleep on yawn folks 91 right down
broadway
did not miss
we got three tickets pack your bags
[Music]
next stop
pound town
10 pitch and that's driven to center
deep back on it martin at the track
right to the wall he'll turn and watch
it fly
center field home run for josh harrison
and the ears take a 12-2 lead
and his first home run is an athletic
for the colosseum the last three innings
has turned into a driving range
he steps all over it
and kaiba if it stays fair it's got a
chance
and how about that three left turns
[Applause]
strike three call martin spins around
heads back to the dugout
four strikeouts for
cole ehrman
marquette is there
cole irvin rolling along folks he's
retired seven in a row another three up
three down
marta
hustling over into right center he's got
it
and that's the ball game
so the a's offense
comes up big today
and cole irvin
terrific outing picks up his eighth win
and the a's
they're starting to heat up they've won
seven out of their last nine they are
now just two and a half games behind the
first place astros in the a.l west